other news
[Laughter]
uh biden
has been given a lot of press
conferences lately
joe biden actually called out donald
trump
he used the phrase my predecessor
but joe biden called out donald trump on
uh the the
insane level of adding adding to the
debt that donald trump did and it's only
insane because of an interview that i'm
gonna read a snippet from from from
march of 2016 where donald trump claimed
he was going to pay off the entire 19
trillion dollar national debt inside of
eight years and instead
what donald trump did was added about
eight trillion dollars to the debt
rather than pay off 19 trillion
uh reading from this article biden slams
trump for racking up 8 trillion dollars
in debt as he vows democrats will pay
for their spending plan by taxing the
rich now listen
a lot of people get caught up in this
debt deficit and they treat the united
states economy as though it's a
household budgeting situation that debt
is bad
and you must have a balanced budget
because that's what you do with your
checkbook
there isn't an analog
with the way a government runs there
isn't a correlation between the two
because it's completely different you
don't print money
in your personal household the united
states government has that power now
save the risks of inflation
it's manageable
reading from this article after months
of negotiations the senate passed
president joe biden's one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill on tuesday a
day later the president made sure
americans knew his economic agenda would
represent a sharp break from president
trump
quote this isn't going to be anything
like my predecessor whose unpaid tax
cuts and other spending added nearly
eight trillion dollars in his four years
to the national debt
eight trillion biden said on wednesday
here
in more full context are those remarks
from joe biden and they're going to be
fully paid for
this isn't going to be anything like my
predecessor whose unpaid tax cuts and
other spending added nearly eight
trillion dollars in his four years to
the national debt eight trillion dollars
they didn't even purport to try to pay
for their tax cuts which went straight
to the largest corporations and the
wealthiest americans
the investments i'm proposing will be
fully paid for
over the long term by having the largest
corporations including the 55
corporations that paid zero federal tax
last year
and the super wealthy
began to pay their fair share
they'll still make a lot of money but
pay their fair share
that means we'll actually reduce the
national debt improve our fiscal
position over the long run
my build back better agenda
is fiscally responsible the fiscally
responsible way to reduce the cost for
families in fact
you're hearing economists across the
board confirm this and you know as a
matter of follow-up joe biden has
promised that he's not going to raise
taxes on anyone making less than
400 dollars a year
so if if you're out there and you make
four hundred and one thousand dollars
per year
good for you
and your taxes are likely going to go up
and that is okay
you have benefited greatly from the
opportunity
and the system that was set up
to provide you the the opportunities to
make that kind of money
for the rest of you which is the vast
majority of you watching your taxes
aren't going to go up even today during
this same press conference joe biden
reiterated
that uh he's not even going to raise the
gas tax that's not something that's
going to happen
so uh the article continues the passage
of the infrastructure plan through the
senate was a major achievement for
biden's build back better agenda and
during his remarks he touted the plans
for creating jobs and boosting economic
growth
among other things he also used this
achievement to criticize the debt that
came from trump's tax cuts saying that
trump didn't even attempt to pay for
them which is a fact
even when things were good prior to the
coronavirus coming on the scene
donald trump was racking up a trillion
and a trillion and a half dollars worth
of debt every single year so all these
republicans out there the mike lees of
the world and the ted cruzes of the
world can zip it
they can pipe down about their concern
about saddling our children with debt
now they can stop it
because you didn't say anything then you
passed overwhelmingly passed a tax
relief bill for millionaires and
billionaires
with no regard for how it was going to
be paid for
how the hole that was left in the
government conference was going to be
made up
we just saddled another 8 trillion
dollars
onto our precious children
you scream
chicken little
according to the federal reserve data
the national debt rose by almost 7.8
trillion dollars during trump's time in
office during that time republicans
approved a major corporate tax cut and
added two trillion dollars to the
national debt a measure many democrats
and economists said favored the
wealthiest americans they said that
because that is the truth
now this is what's interesting
in march of 2016
uh
donald trump sat down with bob woodward
of of watergate fame who still works for
the washington post
and he gave an interview
in which
this particular segment took place this
this interaction took place about the
national debt and what donald trump's
plans were to combat the national debt
and continue deficits and indeed how he
planned to maybe pay down the national
debt
donald trump says
we've got to get rid of the 19 trillion
in debt
obviously i'm reading it in my voice
because donald trump doesn't sound like
me nor does he he's not as coherent
bob woodward replied how long would that
take
i think i could do it fairly quickly
because of the fact that the numbers
and then woodward interjects he says
what's fairly quickly
trump well i would say over a period of
eight years and i'll tell you why
woodward
would you ever be open to tax increases
as a part of that to solve the problem
trump i don't think i'll need to the
power is trade our deals are so bad
woodward that would be two trillion
dollars a year meaning
he would be paying off
two trillion dollars of national debt
every year
but in order to do that you'd need to
not have deficits donald trump
certainly deficits of one and one and a
half and two trillion dollars
aren't going to allow you to be in a
position to pay off
two trillion dollars in debt
trump says no but i'm renegotiating all
of our deals bob the big trade deals
that we're doing so badly on with china
505 billion this year in trade we're
losing with everybody
[Laughter]
and uh republicans ate this hook line
and sinker
they fell for it
bamboozled by a con man by a carnival
barker by a grifter by a charlatan
donald trump did not pay off a single
dollar in debt as i've already
referenced he added 7.8
000
billion dollars
to the national debt
great job republicans
and now that we're we're trying to spend
some money for infrastructure we're
trying to spend some money on stimulus
to keep people from losing their homes
from
to keep people from being homeless
to keep people uh who are unemployed
uh afloat
then they want to ask about how are we
gonna pray for this
it's hypocrisy at its finest
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video